and and my point is that a lot of people  who are clinically depressed are  suffering with something in their life  and if you fix the problem in their life  perhaps they won't feel depressed  anymore but it's not a disease but  Andrew you're not situational Andrew  You're simply wrong  if that's what you believe peers that's  what I believe I don't believe in things  that take power away there is not an  eminent doctor in the world would agree  with this I think you know more than  doctors I can't become clinically  depressed  why do you know because I don't believe  in it  I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't  believe in ghosts well let's say I'm  never going to die because I don't  believe in it it's ridiculous